hey guys welcome to the apple event
coverage i'm gonna be watching it live
and reacting
but obviously this isn't live live so
get hyped
with me while we watch oh boy okay i
need to get my notes open so i have my
notes over here i've got the event here
i've got my coffee i've got mario for
moral support i've got my phone
i've got water wow wow wow
oh there's an apple watch sc oh my god
it's available
this friday this right out oh god i have
not fallen
i'm trying to take notes tweets fight
with people on twitter
why do we need ten dollars a month
picking friday apple is
doing a fitness service
[Music]
shredded i'm gonna be so fit
we're moving on to ipad i don't know
what's happening anywhere
sassing me on twitter i'm literally i'm
i love that craig just keeps getting in
the way every time
he's always hanging out oh there's so
many ipads so many ipads
so little time so it's over it's over
it's over it's like they didn't even
mention the iphone because we know that
there's gonna be another event
now let's talk about everything that we
just saw i'm so excited the event is
over so we're going to go through
some of the things really quickly and be
sure to check out youtube.combrain my
sister and i will be doing
a very in-depth podcast talking about
all of the things that we announced but
i'm just going to go through some of the
highlights
number one the most exciting thing is
the apple watch series six
i am such a huge fan of the apple watch
the apple watch has helped me
actually get in shape and sort of
quantify
what i'm doing is it actually working am
i actually closing my rings am i doing
nothing all day it lets me know we can
now track blood oxygen levels this is
something that i've wanted for a really
long time in the apple watch and it is
now here there is an all new health
sensor on the back that uses infrared
and
you can just track your blood oxygen
just like you normally would
take your heart rate or do an ecg
there's also a new blue aluminum case
there's an updated classic gold
stainless steel and an all-new apple
watch product red
which looks really cool as for which one
i'm going to get
i'm not sure yet the series 6 has 2x
brighter outdoor always on display
and it has an always on altimeter which
is great for hiking
my sister and i used to hike a lot so we
would love to be able to track that so
now that that is something that is on
the always on display is going to be
super helpful there's new watch faces
there's a bunch of new ones
there's a new memoji watch base which is
really cool you can customize it and you
can interact with it
this is the solo loop it is one infinite
band that will go around your wrist and
they have a bunch of different sizes
they said this is one of the most
comfortable apple watch bands ever
and i love the sport loop like this
thing is super comfortable so i'm very
excited to test this out there's no
clasp
no buckle just one continuous piece made
of custom liquid silicone they also did
a
braided solo loop version so this is
made of recycled yarn
also looks cool into the pink color so
obviously if you
have an apple watch you're well aware
that it does have to pair to a phone so
they now have this thing called family
setup which allows users to pair watches
for children
or other family members who might not
have their own phone
or might not have an iphone so say
somebody is
you know over there on team android and
they don't have an iphone but they want
an apple watch they can sync
their apple watch to your iphone and
still have all of the great iphone
features
all of the fitness tracking all of those
sorts of things it just won't link to
their phone
which they probably would want
notifications on i don't know
series 6 starts at 3.99 and there's a
new apple watch
se that starts at 279 so there's a lot
of different options
a varying range of prices for basically
an apple watch
for a lot of different people oh my
goodness oh by the way
available friday no it says you can
order today
today yeah today and it's available this
friday which one are we gonna get what
do you think what color oh my god i'm
gonna
we need we i gotta get it i got to get
what what color
i'm probably gonna get the gold milanese
loop stainless steel
which one should i get i'm shook i don't
know what to do
i think i might get stainless steel or
should i not i don't know what to do
i'm so stressed i can't make decisions
for myself
any longer i think i'm gonna get the
stainless steel wait a minute how
what is the size of my wrist hold on
there's a printable tool
okay so the number between the arrow is
my band size
looks like i'm a five oh god i don't the
one with the loop doesn't ship until
september 25th
well i have five apple watches in my
cart right now graphite stainless
steel it's gonna look really good with a
pink band
moving on apple watch has been ordered
next up is apple fitness plus this is
really exciting because they now have
fitness trainers they have on-demand
workouts that will be coming out they
said by the end of this year
any screen anywhere anytime what's
really cool is it does integrate with
your apple watch so you can get all of
the metrics on screen that is powered by
the watch it is an add-on it is 9.99 a
month this is
really really cool because i feel like
now a lot of people aren't going to the
gyms as much anymore because they're all
closed so being able to have something
like this and work out at home
is super super exciting it says fitness
plus is launching with the most popular
workout types
yoga cycling dance treadmill walk
treadmill run strength
core hit rowing and mindful cooldowns
they've also announced apple one
so this is a way to sort of bundle all
of apple's subscription services into
one thing which is great so for an
individual it's 14.99 a month
you'll get apple music apple tv arcade
and icloud
a family is 19.95 a month you'll get
those same things but you can have that
trickle down to the rest of your family
premiere is 29.95 a month you'll get
music tv arcade icloud
news and the new fitness which is pretty
exciting
next up we've got the ipad so this is
something that has been rumored for
quite a while so this is the 8th gen
ipad they're saying that this is a big
gear for ipad
so earlier this year they did make some
updates to the ipad pro
and today they updated the rest of the
full-size ipad lineups they've got an
a12 chip
40 faster cpu 2x faster graphics the
ipad 8th gen supports full-size smart
keyboard plus existing other third-party
keyboards as well as the apple pencil
they showed off a bunch of demos using
ios 14 which is also
gonna be out tomorrow so exciting next
up
is the ipad air this was an all new
redesign they have
five colors of the ipad air and i was
actually pretty surprised by this when
they started playing the little
intro i was like that's that was those
are colors
there's the new rose gold a green and
sky blue
so now they have five total colors and
before we go any further we just need to
we need to let the class know that there
is touch id
in the power button which makes me so
excited
because this might mean that the iphone
could potentially have this technology
if they're putting this in the ipad air
this this could be setting a precedent
and another thing usbc charging
usb-c and the ipad air i'll stand up for
that one
now give us a usbc in the freaking
iphone
and then we're talking
i now have an elevated heart rate will
usbc charging be in the iphone i don't
know it's in your ipad air you can make
it happen they show this really cool
demo of dj pro
ai it basically like just uses the front
camera and you
can become a dj it's my future the ipad
air starts at 5.99 and it will be
available
next month soon i think one of the
things that i'm really excited about
with the ipad air
is the performance it is going to be 40
faster compared to the previous ipad air
and so many people now are working from
home
kids are using these devices as their
main
learning tool like people are doing
everything completely differently and
using these devices differently
so this is very exciting and it's going
to be a great addition to the ipad
lineup so i'm hyped
i can't believe that everything is is
here now
my friends we wait for the iphone
announcement you guys are new to my
channel hi i'm justine i make a lot of
fun tech videos obviously i'm a huge
apple fan so i will be covering all of
the apple products very extensively here
on my channel
and on my podcast with my sister same
brain so if you aren't subscribed
please do so and hit the bell so you'll
be notified when
i post a new video and we all know that
i just
bought a new apple watch so guess what
you'll see it soon
[Applause]
[Music]
i haven't even thrown anything yet
there's nothing you can throw there's
nothing i can throw it's
there's too many expensive things around
i don't know what i'm doing i need help